have moderates we have anti-trumpers we
have trumpers who are going to love
they are going to love this
infrastructure package when it passes
they're going to act like they don't
like it but believe you me believe you
me when this thing passes you'll have
all these republicans going all over the
country during their 2022 race talking
about how they delivered infrastructure
they're going to
mark my words
because it's popular that's why you
don't see any of them out there
railing against the child tax credit
you don't have em going oh my god that
child tax credit's awful and we need to
get rid of that thing we need to not put
money in your account every month to
help you raise your children
nope not one not [ __ ] one of them not
one of them
they'll say things like oh socialism bad
this infrastructure builds socialism
socialism socialism radical commies
they'll stay stuff like that
and they're not just talking they're not
just talking about the progressives that
are the ones holding this bill in the
house
now i have high confidence
high confidence folks
that there this is going to cave just
like mitch mcconnell and the republicans
are going to cave on the debt ceiling
will the government shut down i don't
know
what shutdown vermont in the week really
[ __ ] unlikely
really [ __ ] unlikely here's the
reason why
it's because the people who have the
interests of the government staying open
are gonna go to mitch mcconnell and the
republicans and say hey
hey
we had fun and all we had fun and all
with your little game with the debt
ceiling and not paying off the debt but
uh you're stopping our payments you need
to turn the faucet back on and i'm
talking about the one percent
yeah yeah they're going to be a little
pissed off when the government shuts
down and they're not making the money
they want to make
it's going to happen
and the republicans are going to get
blamed for this there's 81 million
people that are on to the republicans
here progressives who aren't doing
infrastructure in the house because they
want to one bill to pass before the
other get the [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here with your with
your [ __ ] your your show politics
this country did not want that kind of
politics
let me let me rewind the clock a little
bit and remind you of what happened in
in in 2020
with the democratic primary in this
country
are you ready are you ready people out
there who want to know the [ __ ] truth
who want it straight
everyone thought joe biden was done
bernie sanders was going to win
california bernie sanders is going to
win texas it was over
until they got to south carolina
and joe biden slam dunk south carolina
and then slam dunk state after state
after state after state and it ain't
because joe biden's some kind of special
human being
that's not why
it's because what joe biden was saying
and the message that joe biden had
versus the message that bernie sanders
had bernie sanders had an all or nothing
message it's all or nothing and the
american people are like no no
no all or nothing's not good enough
all or nothing is not good enough we
want something it's been a long
[ __ ] time since we had [ __ ]
done in this country and we want [ __ ]
done and so far
so far progressive democrats you want to
try to stall this thing and spend your
political capital to stall this thing by
the way the president that the people
elected in the primary the candidate joe
biden that they elected to do something
not nothing
the candidate they elected has done a
lot
and done a lot of [ __ ] that he said he
was going to do already
so if you think you're going to hold up
this infrastructure and this
reconciliation package
against 81 million people who voted for
the guy who said he's gonna get [ __ ]
done has been getting [ __ ] done
good luck
good luck to you
i wish you well
in your political career
because your constituents may think
that's great but the american people are
not just like the american people are
not going to put up with joe manchin and
chris and cinema hanging onto this
filibuster much longer for voting rights
are for anything else for that matter
hell two months ago three months ago
most the people in this country would
have settled for some some sort of
compromise on the filibuster to be a
standing filibuster the way that it used
to be in the way it was intended to be
not anymore they want that [ __ ]
dead
you're only pushing the argument on the
other side so democrats rather your joe
manchin and chris and cinema holding up
what the american people want because of
your stupid [ __ ] idea that the
filibuster has to live
we gotta have the filibuster to have
democracy even though the filibuster may
kill democracy oh it makes a lot of
[ __ ] sense
the american people are not gonna put up
with that [ __ ] they're not there's gonna
be an election here soon and you're
gonna see it i think you're gonna see it
virginia i think you already saw it in
california recall
three to one vote
the same way progressive democrats in
the house
if you don't if you if you if you accept
nothing all or nothing
burn it all down all or nothing strategy
in the house with these infrastructure
bills which i don't think they're going
to do
there's one thing that nancy pelosi is
good at and
absolutely destroying
destroying republicans she's the gqp
kryptonite
100 full stop they can't manage her
but there's another thing that can't be
that they can't manage
nancy pelosi either
and that's progressives in the house i
believe she will whip these people into
shape the same way that the the richest
one percent will whip mitch mcconnell
into shape and get this debt ceiling
raised
i have full confidence now
what price us american people pay in the
in the process is the question and
that's where you're gonna pay
that's where you're gonna pay you're
gonna pay political capital by making
the american people wait for you guys to
have theatrics
so you can continue to have your
theatrics and just piss the [ __ ]
voting block
off you can do that if you want or you
can just admit that you were wrong
just admit you're wrong hey the american
people want this and it's better to have
something than nothing this all or
nothing strategy is not gonna work just
come out and just admit it it's fine we
we won't hold it against you and you
know what joe manchin and chris and
cinema if you guys come out today and
say hey that filibuster thing i was just
bullshitting let's get rid of that thing
done
done we're good we're good from here on
out
this is not that difficult it really
isn't it really isn't to get political
capital in this country right now
this this country is not divided it's
united against fascism it's united
against trumpism
they want to overthrow the constitution
of the united states that's what they
want
that's what trump wants that's what
that's what the [ __ ] trump pumpers
want that's what the gqp wants because
they know
they know if they don't undermine the
constitution they won't have power
because the majority of the country
isn't buying what they're selling
anymore and they [ __ ] tied themselves
to what they're selling when they
nominated trump to be the [ __ ]
candidate of their party
i mean even [ __ ] lady g lindsey
graham said it
if he becomes our nominee it will
destroy our party
now i mean
he said that back then and he knows that
now but he's not admitting it
just like mitch mcconnell won't admit
that yeah we're gonna have to raise the
debt ceiling that is something we're
gonna have to do
if we wanna keep getting money from our
donors that is something we're gonna
have to do
his donors are not gonna let him destroy
the credibility
and the credit
of the united states of america they're
not going to let that happen
and he will be blamed for because he
will cave
the same way progressive democrats in
the house
will cave on this bill
they're gonna cave
somewhere something's gotta give
you cannot do an all-or-nothing policy
it it's not a thing that you can do
anymore we voted against that
we the country
we nominated a nominee that was the
opposite of that
the other nominee was selling all or
nothing
all or nothing all or nothing all or
nothing
and it got voted against it was not a
thing that happened we voted for the
candidate that was the opposite of all
or nothing and then when it came to the
general election we voted for the
anti-fascist candidate
so you could say there's unity in this
country and there's a lot of it to go
around
there's a hell of a lot of it to go
around
it just is not with fascist
it's not with fascists so mitch
mcconnell my suggestion is and chris and
cinema and joe manchin my suggestion is
if you want to survive
politically
you might want to be on the opposite
side of fascism
oh and by the way progressive democrats
in the house
with the infrastructure bill to deliver
infrastructure to the american people
because let's let's remind them what's
at stake here this isn't this isn't like
some kind of show thing where they're
naming a post office
we're talking about over five trillion
dollars of money that is gonna funnel
down into the american people and to the
communities red states blue states
metropolitan areas rural areas five
trillion dollars is going to funnel down
in infrastructure and i'm not just
talking about roads and bridges
we're talking about health care
internet
education
there's a ton of infrastructure money
that's going to dump into communities
all around this country and it's going
to lift up the american people
got it
we haven't had a real infrastructure
bill in a long time a real one a [ __ ]
real one a real investment in the
american infrastructure
and by the american infrastructure i
mean the american people
and if you progressive democrats are
gonna say well it's not worth it
let fascism have it let the republicans
have a win let that bill die and let the
republicans win because let me tell you
something let me tell you something
a loss on this bill and a loss on the
work on the infrastructure package and
the reconciliation bill that's already
been done by people in the senate and in
the house democrats only because
republicans aren't there to help
they don't give a [ __ ] about the
american people why would they have
anything to do with this bill
you're with them
you're with them
that's that's the side you're on when
you're against this bill because i'm
going to vote on one before the other
or oh it's got little things in it and i
want this thing in it i don't want that
thing in it get the [ __ ] out of here
quit being little children
and do the thing that you got elected to
do which is go get infrastructure and go
get real [ __ ] policy for the american
people enough of this all or nothing
politics
[ __ ] we are not a divided country
folks
i believe i believe that we are united
against fascism and united against this
[ __ ] [ __ ] where we it's all or
nothing it's all or nothing we're united
against that [ __ ]
that's what i believe i think that's the
truth
ah man you may disagree with me i don't
give a [ __ ] you think the guy who has
[ __ ] on his hat gives a [ __ ]
no
we should be intolerant of the
intolerant
and we should unite where we can unite
and say [ __ ] them to the ones who won't
[ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
you don't want to unite for the american
people and get deliver them the things
that they want need
like that like you did with the
coronavirus package you